one of the things I want to talk about
with you a little bit later today is
that coronavirus is creating a perfect
screen or veil for pushing hyper
nationalist policy in the United States
something that we've seen Donald Trump
and the people around him clearly desire
to do since day one even before day one
of the administration we knew that
bamboozling people with hyper
nationalist rhetoric worked really well
but before I tell you all of the ways in
which hyper nationalism is sort of
rearing its head during coronavirus I
have to tell you about the acute latest
way in which this is happening which is
that Donald Trump announced yesterday on
Twitter that he's suspending all
immigration to the United States under
the pretense of mitigation and public
health and coronavirus safety now this
might be believable if Donald Trump had
been on the side of public health all
along in other cases but he's not been
he's been tweeting about we've got to
liberate states states should open the
countries ready to open Trump is at the
same time understand saying things are
going so well that we can reopen but
things are going so poorly that we have
to stop all immigration to the United
States so by executive order Donald
Trump claims he will suspend all
immigration he announced it last night
on Twitter saying quote in light of the
attack from the invisible enemy as well
as the need to protect the jobs of our
great American citizens I will be
signing an executive order to
temporarily suspend immigration into the
United States now the White House was
asked how long is temporarily what is
the legal basis what's the reasoning for
this no answers on any of those
questions so far and it may indeed
actually not be legal now as a practical
matter most immigration was de facto
slowed down or stopped anyway because
we've got border restrictions and flight
bans so understand that this is all
nationalist propaganda and possibly not
even legal and what I mean by that is
that at the presidential executive order
level it's not clear a president can say
immigration is just suspended but it's a
really
great piece of red meat throw to his
nationalist supporters in practice if
you shut down flights to the United
States from other countries it's hard
for new immigrants to get here if you
shut down crossing at the northern and
southern borders of the United States
it's practically speaking very difficult
for new immigrants to get here so
realize that the policies themselves
that prevent people from coming here
including tourists have been in place
for weeks now which effectively has
actually stopped immigration that's not
really what's at issue what's at issue
is that the announcement that by
executive order Trump is suspending
immigration may not be a legal thing and
it may actually change very little in
practice so why is Trump doing this it's
because he wants to placate his base
with hyper nationalist red meat the
hypocrisy is stunning and you only need
to look as far again as Donald Trump
saying we're ready to open in a whole
bunch of different states we've almost
won against the invisible enemy Trump is
fomenting protests that are demanding
that we reopen and yet he says things
are so uniquely bad that I'm going to do
something that has not been done before
which is I'm going to suspend all
immigration for public health reasons
because we are fighting the so-called
invisible enemy it's completely
incoherent unless you understand that
coronavirus is merely a filter through
which Donald Trump can push his
pre-existing nationalist ideas to fire
up his base we know that this has Steven
Miller's fingerprints all over it much
like America first and a whole bunch of
the other nationalist nonsense that
Donald Trump has been spouting and then
last thing here and then I want to move
on to the bigger hyper nationalist
picture as always with the things that
Donald Trump tweets that he will be
doing sometimes he never actually does
it so we do have to keep an eye on
whether Trump actually does sign this
executive order as of now he hasn't
hasn't done it let's now move on to the
conversation of the ultra nationalism
that is being promulgated under the
guise
coronavirus if you ever feel like you
just don't have enough time to read all
the books you want to read you have to
check out one of my favorite apps called
blinka splink a-- stakes thousands of
popular nonfiction books and distills
each one down into an e-book or
audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book just
imagine how you'll be able to expand
your horizons and knowledge by being
able to soak up all of the important
insights from 10 different books in an
afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book you otherwise
wouldn't have time for or you can use it
to revisit a book you've already read or
use it to preview a book before you buy
the full version and read it I recently
read a brief history of time of course
by the great Stephen Hawking this is a
book that I have been aware of for so
long and other things got in the way and
it was fantastic to check it out on
blinka blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video